I think it's worth talking a little bit
about Rosetta scientists,
Matt Taylor,
now infamous.
Sure.
Sort of what we do here at the nerd
writer talk about morality,
things like that,
but if you think you've heard everything
you ever want to hear about this
subject,
I'll give you a chance to get out now.
Here's an awesome video of a dog trying
to get a tater tot.
I'll see you some other time.
When the sand pepper thing happened a
few weeks ago,
I was drawn to look at it from an
anthropological perspective,
though I wholeheartedly agreed with the
criticism of pepper.
It was the form and impact of the
response that fascinated me most in the
wake of shirk gate.
I just found myself wanting to know who
was right and why.
This is an important exercise,
I think because it took all of three
Internet seconds for arguments about
this to devolve into Straw man attacks
and character assassinations.
Soon as is so often the case in public
discourse,
everybody loses.
The people who were criticizing Taylor's
choice of shirt said essentially that
images like these conserve to dissuade
girls who might otherwise go into stem,
science,
technology,
engineering,
and math fields,
because images like these perpetuate the
cultural stereotype that stem is a boys
club,
just not something that girls do or as
Mike over at idea channel set on his
tumbler.
The shirt was like the coloring on a
poisonous frog.
It's screams.
Stay away to some maybe lots of people,
particularly when Mike wrote about this
in response to a tumbler.
Ask that said,
simply kill yourself.
Not the most articulate way to advance
your argument,
but of course hate is a huge part of
controversies like these.
Not only for those who speak out against
perceived wrongs,
but even those who support those who
speak out.
On the slightly more articulate side,
you have commentators like the mayor of
London,
Boris Johnson who said there must be
room in our world for centricity.
Even if it offends the prudes and room
for the vague other worldliness that
often goes with genius,
and then you have women across social
media who said they weren't in the least
bit offended by tailored shirt and after
all it's just a shirt,
right?
Movies,
TV,
magazines,
billboards are filled with exploitative
images of female sexuality.
Help Kim Kardashians probably did more
to damage young girls image of
themselves.
Then the rest combined.
Why are we crucifying Matt Taylor when
everyone support something or other that
has some kind of misogynistic undertone
when none of us are blameless.
First off,
we're not crucifying Matt Taylor.
We're trying to show how wearing a shirt
like that on a global webcast might add
to a culture of denigration of women.
Second,
it doesn't really matter if some women
aren't offended by Taylor shirt.
What matters are facts,
statistics like these statistics that
show women earn 60 percent of all
graduate degrees yet comprise less than
25 percent of the stem fields.
Statistics that show women are far less
likely to be published in peer reviewed
scientific journals and just is unlikely
to be cited when they are published.
Maybe this is because women just like
science as much as men,
and if you're operating on that
assumption,
there's little I can tell you saved to
suggest that maybe your assumptions are
following from cultural norms,
so invisible.
They seem like insights about gender.
Really the strongest emotion I'm feeling
from the Internet in the wake of shirt
gate is annoyance.
Why do we have to cheapen this
miraculous achievement of science and
humankind with petty bickering about one
man's stupid fashion choices,
and I think this gets to the beating
heart of the matter.
The dirty secret about sexism,
racism,
homophobia,
prejudice is that it's pleasurable,
it's pleasurable to assert your
dominance within a hierarchy.
You create splittable in the same way
that winning at a sporting event is
pleasurable.
The feeling of being a winner of
bettering someone.
So when we think about issues like this,
we have to keep in mind that what we're
talking about is people's pleasure about
taking it away from them rightly so.
Yet,
it will come as no surprise that there
is reluctant to let it go here,
as in any other instance of
gratification in the active sense,
prejudice is easy to condemn,
but in the passive sense,
it's far more insidious to tell
otherwise kind and good hearted people
that by doing nothing at all,
they're perpetuating bigotry,
discrimination,
intolerance to require them to think
about their actions and inactions may
feel incredibly annoying.
That's what it is to take someone's
pleasure away,
pleasure that's so normalized,
so baked into our lives.
It's removal feels a lot like paint.
I for one,
think it's possible to hold two lines of
thought in the mind at once to marvel at
the unbelievable magic of the Rosetta
mission and to lament the real
contribution.
However small of one man's shirt on a
community of women who began at a loss,
so the next time you feel annoyed at
feminists or social justice warriors
were Mike from idea channel.
Take 60 seconds to think about whether
in fact you feel annoyed or threatened.
If it's the latter,
ask yourself,
what is it that I'm in danger of losing?
Hey everybody.
As I said at the beginning of the video,
this is sort of what we do here.
We think about moral issues,
try to figure out what side we come out,
and if we can't do that,
we just try to get a better
understanding of what the issue actually
is.
So thanks for watching.
Make sure to follow me on twitter if you
haven't already,
I'll leave the link in the description
and I will see you next time.